EXTREMIST GROUPS THAT TOOK PART
IN THE INSURRECTION.
>> IT'S REALLY PRIME MINISTER
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU IS FIGHTING
FOR HIS POLITICAL FUTURE.
AS EFFORTS TO GET A NEW
COALITION GAINED TRACTION.
HIS RIVALS FROM THE CENTER LEFT
AND RIGHT ARE WORKING TO FORM A
UNITY GOVERNMENT WITHOUT HIM.
RIGHT-WING LEADER NATALIE
BENNETT ANNOUNCED THE PLAN
SUNDAY NIGHT.
MR. NETANYAHU WAS QUICK TO GO
ON THE ATTACK.
>> THERE IS NO RIGHT WING
GOVERNMENT.
4 ROUNDS OF ELECTION IN THE
PAST 2 MONTHS PROVE TO US ALL
THAT THERE IS SIMPLY NOT A
GOVERNMENT TO BE LED BY
NETANYAHU.
IT'S A UNITY GOVERNMENT.
>> I HEARD ENOUGH CHARLIE
BENNETT.
UNFORTUNATELY, HE IS AGAIN
MISLEADING THE PUBLIC.
SAME LIES, SAME EMPTY SLOGANS
FROM HERE IN THE VISION FROM
SOMEONE WHO GETS A HAND AT
THAT.
AND SOMEONE WHO'S PERPETRATED,
I MUST SAY, THE FRAUD OF THE
CENTURY.
>> IF A FORMAL AGREEMENT IS
REACHED ON THE EMERGING
COALITION, IT WILL STILL HAVE
TO BE PROVED BY ISRAEL'S
PARLIAMENT.
WE ARE JOINED NOW FROM
JERUSALEM WITH ELLIOTT.
THIS --
WENT TO NETANYAHU'S RIVALS NEED
TO DO YET TO MAKE THIS --
AND WHAT IS HIS NEXT MOVE?
>> ROSEMARY, IN PRACTICAL TERMS,
THE VARIOUS PARTIES THAT ARE
OPPOSED AND CLOSE KNIT KNOW
THERE ARE STILL MEETING.
I HEARD FROM A SPOKES PERSON
THAT THEY WILL MEET UNTIL 3
O'CLOCK THIS MORNING.
THEY'RE IRONING OUT SOME OF THE
DETAILS AMONG THEMSELF.
THEY'VE GOTTEN TO MIDNIGHT ON
ISRAEL TIME, 5 PM EASTERN TIME
WEDNESDAY TO GO TO THE
PRESIDENT AND SAY YES I'VE GOT
A COALITION AND I CAN GET THE
VOTES.
THEN IT WILL BE UP TO A WEEK
WITHIN WHICH THE PARLIAMENT
HERE WILL VOTE TO IMPROVE, OR
NOT APPROVE THIS GOVERNING
COALITION.
THEY NEED MORE THAN HALF OF THE
PEOPLE, HALF THE LAWMAKERS TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS GOVERNING
COALITION.
AT THE SAME TIME, THERE IS
PLENTY.
THAT PRESIDENT BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU WILL BE TRYING TO DO
WITH THE SAME.
TIME HE AND HIS SUPPORTERS WILL
BE TRYING TO PERSUADE AND
ENCOURAGE THEIR BASE TO
PERSUADE MEMBERS, ESPECIALLY IF
THE RIGHT WING PARTY TO
DISAGREE, AND OBJECT TO THE
FORMATION OF THIS GOVERNMENT.
OUTSIDE THE TEL AVIV HOME, THE
NUMBER 2 TO BENJAMIN --
THERE BEEN PROTESTERS THIS WEEK
TO TRY AND ENCOURAGE HER TO DO
THE RIGHT THING FOR THE RIGHT
WING BASE AND UNCLE INTO ONE
KENYA WHO WAS DRIVING AS A
RIGHT WING GOVERNMENT.
THE SPEAKER OF THE KNESSET IS
AN ALLY OF PAN AM --
PRESIDENT AT NO.
AND EXTREMISTS COULD BE AN
ATTEMPT TO GET THE COURTS
INVOLVED PERHAPS TRYING TO
SUGGEST THAT THEY RECEIVED A
MANDATE TO TRY AND GET A
COALITION GOVERNMENT AND THEY
CAN'T BE PREMISED OR FIRST.
I'M SURE THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
--
SHENANIGANS ARE GOING ON AND
THEY WILL DO EVERYTHING IN THE
POWER TO TRY AND AVOID BEING
REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
CERTAINLY FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
12 YEARS, WHERE AS CLOSE AS WE
HAVE EVER BEEN TO SEEIN